welcome back the goldstrom's classic car
show who are the sponsors of this next
segment are hosting their annual car
show this Saturday this is your chance
to see their incredible collection for
free I stopped by earlier for a preview
Nostalgia Street Rods is like a
Disneyland for car lovers with over 150
hot rods street rides scooters and
memorabilia and the walls behind this
Disney is the goldstrom family I'm Sheri
goldstrom and I'm the owner of nostalgia
Street Rods
Carrie you know I love you I love your
collection thank you for having us today
the one question I always have is how
did this whole thing start well my
parents collected for 65 years together
and so we decided to just put these
buildings together so that we could show
the community and the world what they
love to collect
um because it's a lot of history and
things that people have forgotten about
yeah there is a lot of history in this
Museum and this weekend is your big
classic car show what can people expect
this weekend oh this year we have some
exciting we have a band A Little Bit of
Country Band we have JC Hackett
um is being our DJ we'll have some
entertainers throughout the day we have
food vendors that are in inventors that
are also selling items plus the
communities bringing over 200 Cars um on
display and then our museums will be
open that day free to the public it's a
car Lover's paradise and you always give
back to Las Vegas any charity times this
year yes Speedway children's charity Las
Vegas chapter and Miss Rodeo Nevada this
year you got two Charities yep amazing
I'm gonna put you on the spot can you
show us your five favorite things uh
sure it's this room you'll find your
fifth favorite thing yes it is this
check from Thomas Edison April 6 1928.
wow for 925 dollars and seven cents
signed by the man himself so JC this is
my number four pick um this is my mom's
49 Chevy Fastback I love the color I
love your mom's connection to the car as
well makes it even extra special for
this weekend can people still sign up to
bring the cars down yes they can um just
go to our website install
tostreetrods.com or call us at
702-876-3652 let's go seed number three
number three you got a 1974 Chevy LUV
truck how did you guys get this we've
had this in our collection for many many
years I believe it was Pepsi cola's
quarter mile car back in the day and my
dad got it and we
love to take it out love to take it out
love to take it out and love stands for
light utility vehicle they made these up
until 1980. this is a very rare truck
that you guys can see this weekend all
right take me to number two for number
two you have a gorgeous tractor for us
JC it's of course not it's Dominique My
Fabulous assistant it is the gorgeous
domination it's great to see you again
what are you looking forward to most
this Saturday I'm most excited for the
public to come out here and see us not
only will we have hot rods on display
for them we're going to have semi trucks
we have some beautiful semi trucks
actually coming out we have this
beautiful tractor cut tons of different
stuff for you guys to see and we'll
actually be open free to the public this
day eight to four all right Sherry it's
time for number one the big reveal what
do we got well if you want to see number
one you're gonna have to come to the car
show this Saturday I'll tell you my
number one my number one is you I love
you so much I love you everything you do
for the car Community come to the car
show this weekend it's gonna be a blast
thank you to goldstrom's Classic Car
Show for sponsoring this segment
goldstrom's classic car show is free to
the public it's happening Saturday this
Saturday from eight to four for more
information visit nostalgia
streetrods.com